once again come with a new charity cause
foundation children of zanzibar to raise
10 000 pounds to feed over 300 families
which is equivalent to 1 000 orphans in
zanzibar pember for free months please
give whatever you can to help us reach
this amount
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below you can also
use the discount code salam 10 for 10 of
their products salaam
and sisters in defense hope you guys are
going today um i read an article and i
found it very profound because
there was a few lessons we can learn
from this and i'm going to jump straight
into inshallah yeah so us left with a
bad name afghanistan's last known jew
taliban's return
a jewish person hailing taliban's return
the two doesn't look like they can mix
let's carry on reading brother sisters
and we can learn some lessons out of
this inshallah
so this man his name is zabilan simentov
as the caretaker of kabul's only
synagogue so there is a synagogue in
kabul right interesting residing in this
compound for decades
simentov has witnessed the civil war
soviet and u.s invasions of afghanistan
the taliban ruled and the group's return
to power 20 years later all his bags
were packed
and zabilan simentov was ready to go but
since the taliban stunning takeoff of
kabul last week semento of afghanistan's
last known jew has had a change of heart
and plans
saying he does not wish to leave anymore
why would a jewish man not want to leave
afghanistan especially when they're
ruling on the taliban
however after talibans brought the sikh
or siege of afghanistan capital on
sunday and the groups pledge to form an
all-inclusive government and not seek
revenge against enemies simentov says he
has chosen to stay in afghanistan his
home for over five decades a few days
ago an afghan came from america with a
plane ticket to take me back to israel i
said i won't go even if the plane comes
outside my home
what a dedication why he told arab news
over the phone from his own from his
home in kabul on saturday if need if
need to protect the synagogue here i see
no threat from the taliban side the
taliban have come they are welcome there
is no fear no threat cement of a carpet
and jewelry merchant added the taliban
have sought to present a more moderate
face since last week's lightning
offensive
me personally i wouldn't say it's a more
moderate i think
hopefully they try to practice the real
islam and not go to extremes of you know
a woman um
i'm not saying where in burka is extreme
but you know to those levels they can't
study they can't all this kind of stuff
you know this is not from islam they
come to the true understanding of islam
hopefully but the group wasn't famous
for its harsh
repressive policies when it ruled
afghanistan afghanistan from 1996 to
2001 before being toppled by the us dead
forces and prompting many to form uh
formerly an exit plan but simentoff who
has served twice in the afghan army
said he would not leave despite his wife
and two daughters moving to israel in
1992 as the caretaker of kabul's only
synagogue residing in his compound for
decades simentov has witnessed a civil
war soviet and u.s invasion afghanistan
the taliban rule and the group's return
to power 20 years later the kabul
synagogue established in 1966
is the only jewish place of worship in
the country after all jews moved to
herat in western afghanistan which once
hosted four synagogues wow so that's in
total five synagogues although
information on the origins of judaism in
afghanistan is
scarce it is believed that jews came to
the region about two thousand years ago
living in relative peace and harmony in
the muslim majority country until the
mid 20th century once a thriving
community in afghanistan thousands of
african jews left for israel and western
countries in the late 1940s after the
creation of israel and after the soviet
invasion in nineteen seventy nine cement
of also uh sims also ex cement of also
expressed
and urged the taliban not to give any
share to these former figures and
militia leaders who have been behind the
country's destruction and instead bring
together
sound and professional individuals from
different ethnic groups and minorities
these leaders have given their tests in
the past have plundered afghanistan and
looted billions their presence will
damage the taliban's credibility cement
said wow this is coming from a jewish
person
despite his hostility towards the
taliban in the past he admits to kabul
and other areas being safer under their
rule blaming u.s leaders for invading
afghanistan and creating destruction and
carnage the us is leaving a bad name in
history by invading here the taliban is
back why did it spend so much money kill
so many people and now leave this way
u.s citizens should not vote for
president joe biden and former president
donald trump both of them are totally
mad he said let's see what comes next
brothers and sisters the prophet peace
be upon him has lived with the jews and
the christians in harmony so much so
that they had a treaty uh with
the
tribes of jewish tribes in medina that
they would protect them and if an enemy
comes that they will protect each other
vice versa even though some of the
jewish tribes of men
broke those treaties but the point here
is that when people think about a muslim
nation this whole notion that there is
compulsion religion is absolutely false
not only do we see this in afghanistan
two thousand years that they've been
living there and there's about what five
synagogues in that country this myth is
debunked once again and the jewish
people have run to muslim lands the
ottoman empire and many many other
empires in history
why because they were persecuted by the
christians yep the crusaders and the
christians who have actually
anti-semitism has derived from because
they believe that their god jesus was
killed by jewish people you know and
that's why the animosity towards the
jews have been rampant throughout
history and the muslims have been a safe
haven for these jews so much so that
one um
rabbi said that if the muslims ruled
around the 19 should say the 40s onwards
we would have 5 million extra jews today
brothers and sisters i'm not going to
keep this video long this was a reminder
to all of us that
muslims live in peace and muslims are
not here to
rule and force coercion you know to uh
islam
uh and that is made clear in the quran
by allah to your religion and to us ours
may allah bless you guys inshallah and
share this with your friends and family
and charbonnet sisters till next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh